welcome to the second morning panel just
one introduce myself porque pero by
Osama in the faculty here in the
architecture school I want to thank
glada for putting together this
wonderful conference which is already
given us so much food for thought we
have a very interesting lineup for this
for this panel with three speakers we
i'm going to introduce each of them
individually as they present you have
the the program on the screen no the
world where the green panel so i guess
that's not on the on the screen but
we're going to start with a paper that
was co-written by vera paula mean and
vladimir bartolini entitled space and
culture bolivian immigrants in the urban
landscape of sao paulo the paper will be
presented by vladimir bartolini
bartolini got his PhD in environmental
urban structures at the universidade de
são paulo writing a dissertation about
municipal public parks he got his
master's degree at the saco de
arquitectura avenues model universidade
de são Paulo where he is an associate
professor of landscape architecture
since 1985 so please welcome Vladimir
battling thank you good morning first of
all I went to taint a Claddagh my name
and name of Vera Paulo me for the
invitation the paper we submit Varian me
submit to the dis conference is about
believing immigrants in some power more
specifically about the way the Bolivian
immigrants practices the landscape we
tried to compare the
usual the daily the ordinary spaces
where this plexus occur or do not occur
to the special space and institutional
the official space where some events
related to believe an immigrant's take
place we assume the hypotheses that are
true landscape arises when it results
results from practice when people social
groups individuals can recognize
themselves in meet I want to do and let
a less remark is that our we didn't do
sociological or demography research the
we got the data the social data
demographic data from other studies
other research or at dawn and available
well the right the the paper was
organizing for parts at first I'll say
something about localities and urban
landscape practices in Sao Paulo and
inform in very wide vision the immigrant
processes of some power and as you know
probably probably know sometimes the
biggest city and the most important seat
in Brazil nowadays in the municipality
about 11 medium inhabitants and 18
million
the metropolitan region it's considered
nowadays a melting pot of racial men in
a ratio and ethical terms but it was
never like that they always started in
the second half of 19th century when the
coffee exports became the locomotive a
Brazilian economy their farms the
plantation de Kock plantation were
located in the state of são Paulo under
the slavery regime of war and as the
slavery regime of work collapse the
slaves were replaced by immigrants
Italian at first Japanese came after and
the Sun Paulo city benefits from its
localization in the convergence point of
the net benefits of day its proximity of
the port of sense Santos the the biggest
sport in the state and the to be the
point of convergence of many railroads
that led to the the farms so in a few
years immigrants moved to the city and
Italian Japanese and as the the city
became a very important industrial and
financial center German came Lebanese
and a lot of nationalities started
living in some power so the immigrants
from different countries
living there as I said but the Italian
ones were the more significantly number
and played an important role in culture
as well in the working classes
organization Italian works in the
majority lived in poor but lively
districts like pariahs mark in this side
of the city or bella vista mo retiro
near the downtown there and from there
they assert and spread the culture of
traces in such a way that nowadays one
can notice their influence in many
dramatic expressions in gastronomy games
customs and so on that are all these
this contribution are shared by every
inhabitant of somehow and Italian reach
to practice the landscape as well for
instance in use of open mapping spaces
in theater in the advertisement of
cantinas the Italian restaurants and
even in what concerns to Japanese
immigrants if they're more distinct
distant cultural customs language and
racial physic features it's possible to
confirm the solid way their influence is
felt in Sao Paulo living at first in the
district next to the central area named
labelled daddy they printed the day
marks in the industry with bars
restaurants shops cinemas and so on
this these districts where they leave it
until now we can see in this district
the first street festivals like San
Gennaro festival or even the average
sunday the the street marketing
liberdade many a decision of the slider
the previous one such a lot of festival
is from adopted Italian community and
although many Italian don't live anymore
in this district the first of all is
going on so they they can backtick they
come back to this street to to
participate to this festival so I would
say that the hood print their marks in a
very effective away even if not living
there anymore so our landmarks can say
if the Japanese is the same but with
Bolivian immigrants things don't happen
like this the purest thing is that they
came from a nearby country and the idiom
they speak is very close to Portuguese
ironically many of them live and work in
the same district square at first
Italian immigrants leave it and work are
very it is dis districts are many of
them are the same that were that were
Italian immigrants leave it some points
can be considered in an attempt to
understand the differences between the
the behavior let's say of the Italian
immigrants Japanese immigrants and
believe immigrants one point is the
demographic one we don't have exact or
even reliable statistics that about the
number of Bolivia Nissan Paulo some
sources inform that they are around two
thousand two hundred thousand others the
half of this amount to the dressmaker
trade union they are eight thousand in
the city of sebab nevertheless all
sources agree that many of them are
illegal among the legal ones the 35,000
are supposed to live in brass district
the ones traditional district of Italian
immigrants anyway they are few if
compared to the number of Italian
immigrants in the first decades of the
10th century or of Japanese immigrants
live in são Paulo since the the middle
of the century that could explain impart
their little presence in the urban scene
and other point is the social economical
one the belief in immigration so Paul we
started at the beginnings of the 19
twink 50s mainly for studies purpose
believin were fewer than they now the
majority of Bolivia immigrants however
started coming to some power from 1980s
all the majority has Louis clarity level
or low qualification in terms of
workmanship and for that reason they
were attacked by jobs
in clothing manufacturers here we have
to take into account economic and
political crisis in Bolivia in the 70s
and the 80s and in which refers to
Brazil geochronology district
lamentation and flexible ization that
took place by the end of military regime
we fit around all consequence more than
the weakening or even disappearance of
former links between labor and capital
increase of a formality the work done at
home it's a quite a different condition
comparing to the time when Italian and
our Japanese immigrants came to Brazil
so the moment that destroyed the moment
is different of course and a third point
so a third point to be considered is the
cultural edge for ethnic or racial
points think taking the risk of using
clichés one can take into account the
different moods or behavior of different
people Italian I early extrovert out
chief Japanese are obstinate persist and
believing are introverted silent to
explain successful or failure attempts
in practicing the landscape one can also
put the lights over the ratio features
that make believing easily recognized as
different what would bring some
difficulties to them but the Japanese
were different as well in developer
integrated anyway we must to be cautious
maybe the clue stay in many reasons but
it's difficult not consider that poverty
and illegal condition are serious
obstacles for the full expression of
believing immigrants in public space
believe in small apartments or in houses
that
being subdivided in small rooms like
Muslims let's see and rarely be go out
now I'll consider the spaces of everyday
life the clothing manufacturers
manufacturing due to their lowest
clarity level and lack of professional
qualification many believing immigrants
find jobs and close to manufacturers the
work road team is hard there as they are
Beth paid for this work men of them
worked 14 or 16 hours a day many
believin workers live in the same place
where they work in precarious in the
environmental conditions children stay
in the same place where their parents
work without the request scares in the
last year's the public ministry an
autonomous entity responsible for the
defense of a legal order reached to
reduce the employers illegal procedures
against the workers making bleeds clots
in unit vectors but even so exploitation
the goal goes on and the lack of
opportunities in that country forces
believe immigrants to accept such a
precarious condition of works of the
conditions of work instability in
formality low salaries confinement
another aspect of everyday life is the
streets and square what happens in the
streets where they work and live because
that belief and immigrants produce are
exposed and sold in popular shops
concentrated in districts like vaca tion
body and their people a lot of people in
general the goals up and downs along
sidewalks every day mainly on Saturday
some of the shop windows where goods are
displayed try to imitate be more
sophisticated shopping center while
others exhibit big piles of clothes song
desire is arranged by customers but
never in any case one can see the
faintest trace of a believe an immigrant
culture in this commercial very streets
and hardly one can find believin walking
among the crowd they are all working in
clothing manufacturers of course at you
2001a believe in street market was held
every Saturday in my square in the very
heart of this district body things for
its popular clothes shops however
residents and traders of the district
pressured the municipality to transfer
the street market to another place under
the allegation that it was planted steam
and cause traffic jams dirtiness noise
and so the street marked was removed to
another square isolated end almost all
the time although not more than one
kilometer far from the former place
there are no house no windows or doors
open to the square it is surrounded by
all by walks few people live next to
each the blocks are mainly for
industries and institutions only on
Sundays the square get some fatality
meanwhile the street market is going on
the square means is con tutta can to the
squares it's a conquest of the believing
community since it is the name of a
flower that grows in the
this and shows the corners of Bolivia's
flag I think that's important to point
here that the more people are far from
home the more they turn to their deepest
telluric roots cheap cold dishes and
food are sold in stores as well as some
traditional believable wore clothes they
play music in fourth we find their g
items we normally find in street markets
but it lacks fatality nevertheless it is
an address where they often attend in
order to keep a bit of their identity
and also to make personal or working
contacts one thing that attacked our
attention was an agglomeration of
standing people young people in general
which changed among them a small piece
of the white paper that they kept
carefully there in these papers where we
tend the names addresses or telephone
numbers of people who wear who wear the
demanding work or offering jobs yes
totally apart from the difficulties
believing immigrants finding their
everyday life to live a full citizen
condition there is an official space
where theoretically the integration
between Latin Latin America people must
occur the Latin America memorial latina
many more with a 28 cruiser in Barra
funda district designed by oscar
niemeyer inaugurated 1989 aiming to
promote the latin american culture
cultural integration but all your fish
official events are hold there in this
point of view it falsifies the reality
lived by believing immigrants in sao
paulo the very way it was planned and
built reproduces the old and worn flats
of altering Reggie
to inaugurate monuments it consists of
the isolated buildings to control the
time I will only show i think that the
photographs can speak for her by
themselves as only a sculptural isolated
buildings a very hard pavement square
big one which can I can save more than
30,000 people but it's a everyday empty
it except in first of all occasions it's
very near from the unimportant bus and
train a subway station from which leave
and arrive buses connecting Bolivia and
some photo recently the memorial allowed
the memorial in the station will allow
the consulate of believer to use an
annex to provide documentation for
immigrants probably probably this could
help Latin America memorial to be a
reference for believing immigrants
probably it is a red but not in the way
that one kept could recognize himself in
its landscape and just to finish I will
say some words about the merging
landscape the colibri street or the
little Bolivar let's say in spite of the
poverty and stability that typified
situation believe immigrants in Sao
Paulo an embryo of the natural landscape
can be detect we refer to Congress
Street in balance district where start
appearing some restaurants LAN houses
hairdressers little shops that are run
by an aim to believe and immigrants it
is easy to notice the little believe
it's concentrated two blocks only
nothing is ostensible only a few
elements stand out but they are enough
to indicate the affirmative presence of
believing the science consists of a
different Iseman written in Spanish I
know that here is common that but in Sao
Paulo is not common to find some
advertisement written in another
language than Portuguese during the
weekdays the the the converse it is
called however it reaches change on
Saturdays when a lot of belief
immigrants come to have their haircuts
cut too short something or just to meet
their fellows just one minute just the
unfinished there are an important
difference between 10-2 T Square and put
a kalimba street we can say that quarry
street was born in a more natural way
without institutional support without
previous authorization as the
manifestation of a little force
expressing the simples everyday
activities the tranquility that we
noticed in Coimbra street is in the
weekdays it is like the the one who came
experience in a friendly space land ho
GA uses a play on words just to finish
now play on words that make sense only
in French but it is very interesting and
feeds way out to refer to one of the
most important conditions that landscape
offer to us the comfort to recognize a
need the clue is to read the word pizza
that means landscape as the sum of P
the country place and Sasha that means
sensible also peaceful not bad cause not
aggressive this seems to happen in
coimbra Street the last slide the
calmness of this bit of vanilla
contrasts strongly with the daily
agitation of the streets where the shops
and clothing manufacturers are placed
and well believe believing immigrants
only half innings of work it also
contrasts with the desolated can put
this squared on the weekdays it
contrasts finally with the solemn almost
inaccessible inaccessible and even
enough for in not suitable Latin America
Memorial and the streets around it in
Coimbra street is possible to have a
long and relaxing talk with believe
immigrants despite their complaints
about prejudice or hostility they suffer
even in the disguised way Bolivian
immigrants we approached by chains in
Canary Street seems to be more talkative
and secure than others we met in other
places it seems that there they feel at
home it seems that a vernacular
landscape is coming up there excuse me
thank you very much
Thank You Vladimir and we moved from
Bolivians in Brazil to Peruvians and
Brazilians in Japan our next presenter
is erika rossi she is a PhD candidate at
the Global Studies Institute faculty of
sociology at hiku hito Tsubaki
University in Tokyo she obtained her MA
and global studies at the Global Studies
Institute faculty of sociology of hito
Tsubaki University in Tokyo again and
her most recent work is centered on the
revival in recent years of cumbia paid
wanna among the Peruvians in Japan the
title of her paper is music takes place
mapping latin music places in japan
please welcome Erika Russell thank you
and thank you Clara for the invitation
well today I'm proposing a musical
perspective on transnational Leighton
Americanism since late two thousand for
my research as focus on how Peruvian
migrants has produced place through
music and today in particular I will
deal with Peruvian migrants music
practices in Japan so let me start with
some theoretical premises so why music I
find music suitable for the
understanding of migration and
transnationalism in four aspects first
mobility is the essential characteristic
of sound in this respect music has the
power to cross spaces to cross borders
create places destroy them and remaking
them in you the second the music often
spread as a consequence of human
movement that is migrant populations
often brought the music with them to the
new areas of settlement thirdly music
and its capability to create places
forces us to think about places as a
constant process as not as something
fixed in the same way human migration
putting questions the idea of pleasure
forces us to new conceptualization of
them finally music as I understand
it is a human practice and human
activity so by the word music I don't
mean a genre or something you can write
down on a score but the human activity
where different actors participate my
methodology for this work has been that
of mapping to parallel music scene one i
collated music scene and the other one I
call the decas a Latino seen in the
first one mainly japanese participate
while the second one is mainly made up
of migrants or de casa which is the
japanese word for foreign workers before
i enter the description thank you of the
two scenes let me briefly introduce my
theoretical setup I want to establish a
relation between the concepts of music
scene and transnational social space
following stro a music scene is
different from a musical community
because it has no tradition to
perpetrate it tends to go beyond the
place music is performed thus it tends
to be linked to a wider music market and
the participation of different actors
from event organisers to occasional
participants is the prerequisite for the
making of the scene in a similar fashion
I think a transnational social space is
multi-dimensional and it is constructed
through the recurrent transnational
interactions and practices worldwide and
implies the participation of multiple
social actors in this sense the music
scenes I'm going to present here can be
considered trans local or transnational
music scenes though the actors
participating them are very different
and their practices have very different
outcomes in terms of the creation of
social relations that are finally
reflected in spatial terms I have mainly
three points or like there are three
possible outcomes from this perspective
one is related to the conceptualization
of transnationalism that is the
necessity to consider those aspects of
transnationalism which are not limited
to migrant prac experience so this kind
of transnationalism is shown by the lady
music scene
this kind of transnational practices
together with the migrants transnational
practices that keep life to the DECA
segi music scene the Latino one once
again we we confirm the argument about
the low level of integration of Latin
American migrants into Japanese society
to describe this situation specifically
I use the expression coined by the by
Professor cachita in what I think is the
most complete work ever written about
Latin Americans in Japan that his cow
nami ni te doja that's invisible
residence and thirdly I want to argue
that the processes that underpin the two
scenes are reflected in special
practices that reveals their imbalances
in the relation between Peruvian
migrants is a case in point for the
Latinos in Japan and their relation with
Japanese society so before I enter the
concrete descriptions of the sea let me
give me a brief panorama about Peruvians
in Japan because probably is not a very
well-known theme so as a consequence of
the new economic growth idea during the
80s Japan identity ages Japan was
affected with a serious shortage of
labour force in its manufacturer
industry especially automobile and
electron home electronics sector so
after is of discussion finally the new
immigration law was issued in 1990 the
law allowed all Latin American of
Japanese descent until the third
generation to enter Japan with a
permanent visa of Earth three years in
this sense the law was based on a racial
prejudice according to which Japanese
descendants were considered to be easily
assimilated into Japanese society in
virtue of the degree of the of their
japanese blood the migrants were called
de casa guild OSHA that is for temporary
workers and 90.6 % these data are
updated to 2005 are employed in a were
employed in factories related to the
automobile and home electronics sectors
for this reason the DaCosta Gerudo
dodeca segi
workers and is characterized as the one
employed and the 3k job that his kid and
I dirty kid sooo hard and he can't
dangerous another main characteristic is
that the day kasagi door for the
temporary workers entered Japan as
flexible labor force to be moved
according to labor market needs this
mobility is so good for the Japanese
labor labor market and to some extent to
the Michaels because it was very easy to
skip from one job to another was in fact
a great entrance to the integration of
foreign workers into Japanese society in
fact together with the fact that Japan
internal does not have an immigration
policy the flexibility of migrants has
prevented them to accumulate the
necessary social capital for an
effective integration for this reason
the de casa gr invisible residents that
is there are no more residents in the
sense that they are well established in
Japan's there is 20 years have passed
since they first enter the country but
see their faces are unseen to mainstream
Japanese society so I argue that this
situation is reflected in music
practices to this is a very simple
handmade map of Japan but the majority
of Peruvian are located in the
industrial areas or can't cantil to boo
and kinky regions and these are also the
places where the main deck asagi scenes
are to be found on the control the main
ladii music scenes that is the one made
of the Japanese ought to be found also
in Tokyo which is the capital the
biggest biggest in encanto el encanto
area nagoya and osaka but in the center
of the city so we have for Tokyo we have
the Roppongi which is the entertainment
center of the city we have a small area
called Sakai for Nagoya and we have a
very restricted area in Osaka made up of
two or three clubs no more so today I'm
gonna talk about two
main since the one happening in Roppongi
and one happening in the occasion
industrial area the cake in industrial
area links Saitama Prefecture which is
born with Tokyo in Saitama Tokyo and
Yokohama it's all and the soil area were
and in the Yokohama Kawasaki area a big
latino population is to be found so this
is the most important music scene as far
as kanagawa prefecture is concerned so
briefly the main differences between the
two music scene is that as far as the
late music scene is concerned the
Japanese music scene is due to the
revival of layton music in Japan
occurred during the 90s this is a trend
we can see in other parts of the word
but in Japan the commercial strategies
that preceded them vendors when is a
social club movie were determinant is a
consequence the Japanese Latin music
market which is very very small is still
dominated by Cuban music with Cuban
salsa standing out the makers of the
scene together with media and event
organizer are mainly japanese middle low
middle high income furnace and those
latino living in downtown Tokyo or
mainly working in downtown Tokyo every
club of these letting scene offered
dance classes they are off after work
dance class is very important to track
nuclear fly until under this log and the
Latin dance helps you in fighting stress
or lose weight so in the words of
Japanese percussionist friend of mine
salsa boom is nothing but diet boom so
because the main target are young we
young career women in their 30s or white
colors working in the in central Tokyo
clubs open very earlier around six
o'clock with classes starting a dance
classes starting around 7pm the night
ends early for the Japanese you usually
leave the scene around midnight with the
last train at the weekends after
midnight mostly foreigners are to be
fine there the clubs in Roppongi work
seven days a week and they are everyday
open till five
six o'clock in the morning all clubs are
located maxima 10 minutes walk from
Maine subway stations to be found in a
low pony the DaCosta gay music scene
offer a different panorama because it's
mainly made up of peruvian which are the
biggest Latino community in Japan they
are almost 60,000 people in the last
five six years cumbia piranha is the
music genre which makes the main
distinction with the lady music scene in
terms of music perform cumbia has always
been underrepresented in Japan and this
is a very different situation from what
happens for example in my country Italy
or hearing New Jersey partisan that are
all other locations where I conduct
filled with the reason might be that
most of migrants Peruvian migrants in
Japan are of middle-class origins and
come from the coastal city that is that
are part of that social class that
always miss regarded cumbia as musica
para todos nonetheless with the revival
of cumbia Peru a revaluation of the
genre occurred in Japan this fact is due
to the role of media in the Peruvian
community in fact considering the small
population like barely sixty thousand
people scattered in the in the three
areas I showed before and we have five
regularly nationwide Spanish language
publication seven Internet era
broadcasting Peruvian TV well half of
them are illegal and to internet radio
and without considering the high
activity of Peruvian restaurants and
shops that they will get illegally DVD
among which we find the TV series made
in Peru peaking of the stories of the
formation of cumbia bands so as far as
the synthesis also part of the scene
which usually start later after midnight
and takes place just once a week mainly
on Saturday because while the hard work
schedules in Japanese factories and
because of the low economic power of
migrants population they would not be
cliental during
the other weekdays so the clubs in order
to keep cheap prices are located far
away from train stations open a minced
industrial areas or counter style in
fact it is not in common that they offer
pickup service for those coming by train
next I will I will show you not pictures
but a small video i edited because well
a documentary is part of my PhD thesis
so I picked up some Akira from my
ethnographic work and I'm gonna show you
what I'm order said right now in a very
simple Freeman expedia and with music
Oh
you
but what I was trying to demonstrate is
that both things are transnational but
in different aspect one wonder the Latin
music scene the dough maintaining a
local color is linked to a wider
community of taste for me Ron Latin
music the other the casa de one is made
possible by migrants practices of media
consumption and their participation into
the country of origin music scene though
this difference should rise questions
about the social factors that makes this
possible in the sense that the two seen
especially the 2 i've shown out are very
close actually between low pongy and
well it was yokohama kawasaki area they
are like 30 minutes by train which is
nothing in a in a in an area like
contrary so in spite of this fact there
is really no communication between the
two scenes and it reveals in some sense
the low level of communication between
Myron's community and Japanese society
and migrants transnational practices are
under under undoubtly plus places for
self-expression that is from music
businesses are set up and bands are
formed and this point has been very much
threatened by Japanese scholars however
especially using the concept of
transnationalism from below they try to
demonstrate how migrants really
expressed and sell through ethnic
business and things of the like however
the intensely the intensity or the
intensity of transnational practices on
the behalf of Peruvian migrants are not
limited to music they spend fields as
various as education food and shopping
in this sense transnational practices
were vital in sustaining Peruvian
community during these two years but at
the same time reinforced its isolation
from Japanese society if we see the Nana
in another way unwittingly
legit legit mutated the day Cassidy
discourse introduced by Japanese society
that had no reason during these 20 years
and this is very much a debate right now
in Japan when this 20 years japanese
government had no necessity of a few
exception to get involved the
integration of its invisible residents
and now with the two thousand a
recession that strongly hit japan nice
automobile and home electronics sector
in particular all these problems are
coming out very strongly so Japan should
stop seeing it's my Wednesday kasagi in
order not not only to develop an
immigration policy but to help the same
migrants to abandon their day Cassidy
mentality Thank You Erica our next
speaker is rosyth aveda she obtained her
PhD from the PO technic university in
madrid she is now a professor and
director of the master's program in
architectural design in the city at the
University of alcalá and she's the where
she's a former dean of the school she's
the co-director since 1993 of
architecture and bionic our
international workshop in gwent Spain
and a partner in debt aveda NGOs
architects she has received several
national and international architectural
awards longer than we can mention here
and the title / paper today is city
inside a city Latin American immigration
in the neighborhood of theta 1 by Death
Valley faas in Madrid thank you please
welcome
well first thanks Clara and mainly
congratulations congratulations for
bringing bringing the Latin American
debate to an institution like Columbia
University I think it is really
remarkable so we are talking these days
about these people this is the city of
El Alto in La Paz Bolivia people that is
forced to move around the world because
economical reasons they have to live
families homes change everything habits
event sometimes languages more than most
of them coming from South America and
Central America to Spain we are focusing
on these theme in Spain the phenomenon
of immigration is really rezoned of
course in the contemporary Spain not in
our long history in the last decade we
have increased immigration from the two
percent of the total population to a
17-percent we have more than four
million eight hundred thousand legal
immigrants an unknown number of illegal
and the most largest the largest
communities are Ecuadorians Bolivians on
Colombians here is the map of the people
coming to Spain and Latin American are
mainly based on the east coast the
Mediterranean coast and of course in
Madrid the Cimmerian mean social
segregation the two main concern of
immigrants are jobs and housing I'm
access to housing depends on access to
work so we find here the link between
the social aspect on the special aspect
as an architect I am going to talk
about the special aspect of immigrations
how do immigrant communities occupy
leaves the city other reason for that
way of occupation or how to improve
these settlements are the questions to a
start but mainly is the issue properly
considered at the academia it's properly
consider in university so we decide that
it is it was not an it was in our
University alkali University very close
to Madrid in the master universitario
project avanzado and architecture 80
that we decide to focus on this theme
here is my school and we work in the
city of Madrid where we have now more
than a hundred thousand immigrants most
of them Latin American in process
immigration process linked to the
construction we boom we have lived in
the last 10-15 years and now is recently
stopped where the immigrants are located
in the city is a very important question
we have had a very intense process of
internal migrations of National
immigrations between nineteen fifty-five
and 19 17 1 million people came from the
rural areas to a small towns to Madrid
so we have dealt with with this problem
and there are proven thesis that show
that internal immigrants plays close to
the roads that link that lead to their
hometowns how the foreign immigrants
plays are located in the city well they
are placing first in a first 33 a
neighborhood of low-income workers
neighborhood but almost also in the
center areas in different neighborhoods
with low and with high incomes the most
famous
his lab appears is a multicultural
multiracial a neighborhood of
immigration a long history from the 16th
century we are working on Tetuan cuatro
caminos in the northern part of the city
this is the area the total area you can
see a two different urban fabric the the
road on the right is the main street of
the city paseo de la Castellana city of
Madrid they probably the most valuable
valuable area with averey thank you very
much with her here a regular fabric and
you can compare the other part this
almost chaotic fabric where we are
working on were the immigrant our place
but the starting point for our students
to work to deal with what the recycled
city what does recycle city means the
cycle is recycling is something that we
refers usually too much videos in order
to to reuse materials in a process of
continuing process to prevent waste and
to save energy but now we are using for
the city what does recycle city mean
well when our city grows expands
occupying territory we could say
occupying occupation and the predation
of territory of course an excessive
increase of mobility increase of energy
consumption and pollution decrease of
urban activity and public safety
decrease of nature and biodiversity so
what we propose is just the contrary in
order to find an efficient city with
high density unlock a low consumption of
course control land of land occupation
increase of density
activity but improving urban quality
introduction of nature in the city
tendency to zero energy and construction
of the 3d city we starting a mythology
of researching all the approaching to
the province of the area with a student
a group of them work on social and
economical aspect showing this kind of
information for example the Pyramid of
me as you can see is not a pyramid shows
that there is a lot of old people in the
neighborhood and a lot of immigrants
coming in the last ten years most of
them from Latin America the question is
why is that one Balderas chosen as a
place to live by Latin America community
well of course is a very well place
inside the city is in mobility and
public transport something very
important for newcomers commercial area
and close proximity to the new cvd here
you can see a map of the many lines
halfway on buses around the city and
here is the new district the most
valuable and representative fairy of the
city with the oldest buildings down by
famous architect you can see from the
inside the building how close were where
we are so this second question should be
why then that one is a neighborhood for
immigrant community well of course there
are historical and geographical reasons
that produce a permanent degradation of
the built environment that produce a
permanent low low prices of housing this
work conclusions that the students
arrive here is the city of Madrid at the
beginning of the 20th century the center
as you can see the extension of the 19th
century are outside this informal
settlement with a very chaotic chaotic
layout of streets so we can see these
spontaneous settlements not planet
organization of land and irregular
division of plots remain a long
centuries producing a territorial
display like this with labyrinthian
layout uncomfortable journals on cool
desert or detain streets on the other
side if we look at the plot we could
consider that these are playing ground
but it is not in fact is they are folded
afforded the hill very rough topography
that produces precisely these
uncomfortable spaces so this is a
typical section or typical profile of
the streets of the neighborhood that is
not very friend what we find in many
cities in in South America poor people
occupying the most uncomfortable places
so there are historical reasons that
remain in the modernity even the
original main that one that one de las
victorias refers to the victorious
armies coming from Africa in early 19th
century with soldiers from the city of
Tetuan and place in that place owed the
conclusion is the this neighborhood is
for retired people with their wheat I
people an immigrant in some way is a
social segregation due to economical
reasons the study of the topologies is
really very complex because it's not
uniformity is a residual fabric of
buildings many types many sizes many
highs from one level to 10 impossible to
clarify to have a complete plan of the
total you can see the landscape even the
new buildings then you one that are in a
process of substitution of the old ones
it doesn't improve too
the place the place is a rural character
popular character we could say
historically today is changing very
nicely with this new new foreign people
coming from Latin America this kind of
neighborhoods for sending money for cold
to their country to to buy products of
Paraguay lat like in this case or Latin
fashion one hundred percent sexy some
very very nice in a survey with a small
survey we did of course very very not
scientific sorry with the neighborhood
day they said this neighborhood looks
like South America or most important
this district is again alive thanks to
immigrants because they are bringing
young people to the area if we take a
look of the households we appreciate
that a third of them are not formed by
typical families we can understand for
typical families that formed by two
adults and two or more one two three
children but now we find a lot of
households with only one arrow usually
all people & Son of them formed by two
or more families and or by in single
individuals without any familiar
relation there was an a new recently
with an apartment about 60 people living
inside so it has previous abuses to the
foreign people and it is something that
the authorities are not doing anything
to improve so even if we take a look of
the standard family the standard family
know so much as we as we consider two
adults or one mother what with children
of other with children so if we analyze
the housing the old ones are there new
ones even the new ones that resin
learn that is a problem a real problem
overcrowding and housing collapse this
design oriented to the traditional
family inadequate housing design and
inflexible and far from reality social
housing law this should we change of
course the response of the students part
of the work on these new proposals for
housing producing for example housing
for single people sharing temporary
housing John CalPERS two families hunger
and sharing and so on some of them work
on substitution of some blocks other
preferred to destroy and to change
completely the blocks or very
interesting solutions were to work on
the interspecies this is small spaces in
3d mean 3d dimension as you can see
completing the profile of the of the
city but remaining the all buildings in
order to preserve identity other
question very important was the the
ugliness of the urban landscape as you
can see here if we ask again to the
residence so no then it say said what I
must like is that there are all kind of
shops what I don't like is the lack of
security but badly lit the streets and
so on Oh what I must like is that you
can find everything and cheap is cheap
but I don't like it's not all the street
as home or more stimulated on't like
anything this place is a so I think
a public space is a right for citizen
and I want it for the integration of
immigrant some one of the students work
in this line open public spaces and
making an Una's punchy design sponge at
the city 22
who prefer to proportionate places for
gathering generating this kind of
squares or another solution very smart
solution two corridors crossing the
uncomfortable journeys but this corridor
was was trying to do was to avoid the
slopes and they go up and down of the
streets generated like a bridge green
corridors rim bridge corridos that put
even have buildings over or an F of
green spaces not only in the ground
level but in the roof level and even
trying to find some indicators
sustainability indicators about that
another idea was to compound activity
very intense in this area with the
almost no activity in disorder
generating cultural center or different
markets in the opposite part of the plot
or even working inside the blocks
liberating space inside these blocks i'm
generating like a second grid of green
spaces inside so this is the real there
are here are the real authors of the
work people as you can see most of them
coming from Latin America so here we
find again the transnationalism links
with between countries and in the rear
part you can see University of alkyl
alcala University of alcalá was founded
500 years ago precisely to form to
educate civil servants who had to travel
to then call new world again the trip
going back going forth from one area to
order of the world here is a
almost finished that we are preparing
about the things we have been working
this last two years above the recycle
city thank you very much
the tables
so I want to thank all of you for some
really thought-provoking and interesting
presentations rather than address
individual questions to each of you
which I will also do my hope is that we
can have a little bit of a conversation
amongst ourselves and then we can hope
hopefully open it up to questions from
the audience just a briefly remark on
what I what I think's are some of the
themes that tie the presentations
together and and which we could talk
about it seems to me that uh three
presentations deal in some in one way or
another with a human cost of the liber
liberalisation of economies and the ways
in which people have developed coping
mechanisms to deal with those with those
costs and the trauma of displacement in
the case of Rosa I thought it was very
interesting even you begin with your
title of city within a city would
suggest the importance and the relative
independence of neighborhoods a city
understood as a series of neighborhoods
and the fact that this relative
independence gives a kind of opportunity
to to create a sort of identity for a
group to take over a kind of
neighborhood and establish a new
identity within it I thought it was
really a great and incredible analysis
of the urban space and the sociological
conditions that allow for immigrants to
take possession of these of these places
and and make them their own and I was
really a you gave us a really
interesting picture
what's happening in terms of the aging
population and the undesirability of the
place over time for locals and how
certain populations are in a sense
forced into the public space and I
thought that as a pedagogical exercise
which you presented it as a kind of
studio it was really a great great
pedagogical exercise for students to
engage and and it resonates with the
with a notion the larger notion of
immigrant neighborhoods which which
bloody mar you also dealt with and of
course we dealt with some of these and
other and other panels like and talking
about in the morning we were talking
about 10 site is but also people
mentioned New York Lower East Side and
so on so this this typology of the
immigrant neighborhood is really quite
interesting and maybe something we can
also talk about what makes an immigrant
neighborhood these kind of transitional
neighborhoods and I would like to
propose this with this word you know
that we think about this notion of
transition the transitional neighborhood
a place where you kind of recognize you
take hold but it's also a place for for
something else for moving into another
place it's a place of movement from one
place to another and historically we
thought of immigrant neighborhoods is
precisely that the place in which
assimilation takes place so the attack
the you know the Italian Little Italy
over here isn't again you also don't
have Italians there anymore but there's
this sense that it was the the launching
pad for them to become assimilated into
the larger culture something that's not
happening in Japan as you pointed out
institutionally also very much kind of
instrumentally so they're kept out of
integration so that's for me also
something we could talk about you know
them a part of the cost of
liberalization is this idea that we no
longer have access to that this
transition that immigrants can no longer
in a sense fully penetrate the host
society and there I thought it was very
interesting bloody marys paper moving
so that that you gave us really some
great examples of why half traditional
immigrant neighborhoods stopped working
as traditional immigrant neighborhoods
you focused on the brass neighborhood
which had received waves of Italians of
Japanese of Chinese and now the Bolivian
somehow are not are not being able to
take over those that neighborhood and
partly because of preservation I suppose
establishing a certain moment in time
this is now the Chinese neighborhood and
it becomes a kind of place that is
identified with with a previous
immigration wavin and but also partly
because of this life liberalization of
of lay of the economy and the way that
that has caused a kind of prep
precarious working conditions the
prepares a shin of work is something
that I think is also very clear in both
Erica's paper and bloody marys paper
less so I think in Rafah and process
paper because I think the situation in
Spain's a little bit different in terms
of the kind of working conditions but it
might be now that the building boom has
stopped that now that they're all this
might become a kind of apparent so this
i thought was also a theme that maybe we
could talk about the procerus a shin of
work as something that involves the the
permanent movement of the working class
the denial of housing the permanent
housing the denial of kind of the right
to housing which you mentioned and I
like the fact that you were very kind of
upfront about that the need to really
vouch for that but really this is this
is somehow being the night so in some
way the stat that what we traditionally
conceive owes the immigrant that status
of immigrant is in a sense also being
denied in a sense that the right to
adequate housing is being denied so it's
interesting that within this panorama of
the procerus a shin of work and the
and in the human cost of liberalization
we have things like music which were
secondary to housing at a certain you
know historically in terms of kind of
giving in a foothold in a place for
people becoming primary so I thought it
was Erica's paper it was very
interesting and how important music has
become in the absence of other things
the the paper on sapelo so I thought
really brilliantly described the many
sleight of hands that are happening that
on the one hand by governments on the
one hand housing is being denied but on
the other hand there's these
neighborhood sized institutions that are
being created like the Latin American
culture monument which is supposed to in
a sense present immigrants with a
possibility of a space within the city
but at the same time denies them free
access to them and only have allowed
them a very ritualized access to to
those spaces so there's this kind of
sleight of hand there that I think is
something for us to also talk about in
relationship to industrial working
hiring practices and so on in industrial
Japan now Erica's paper i thought you
know really made me think most intensely
about the idea of trauma and
psychological trauma and i think that
maybe this is something that we could
also push to the fore because i think
this panel more than any other panel has
dealt with with the with the with the
human suffering in a sense that that
these migrations involve with a sense of
loss that having to go to somewhere else
forward creates you speak about music as
a as a relief even if it's a temporary
relief that's going to a party is a
temporary relief from the anxiety of
homesickness and this question of
homesickness i think is really important
to discuss maybe we can talk about this
the experience of
transnationalism you know which is a in
many cases are very very difficult and
an traumatic experience and you speak
about the home country Peru as the home
country for these recent immigrant maybe
I could replace that with motherland and
you'll see why I do that because I think
instrumentally you know you signal
towards the importance of the emotional
but but I felt like we didn't get far
enough there and maybe we can draw some
of that out and I was thinking in
particular of the mother in the
motherland let's the land but more the
mother and I was thinking of Winnie cot
was you know was the one of the founders
of child psychology and in his thinking
about the development of the child he
coins this term the transitional object
which is something which is usually a
physical object which takes the place of
the bond between child and mother and
you know the common things are like a
doll or a teddy bear or a safety blanket
you know those of you that have had
children know about this but it could
also be a song could also be music
that's my song and those transitional
objects of follow Winnicott have the
role of an intermediary developmental
phase in which the child realizes that
she is different from the mother for the
first time and begins to feel that she's
lost something and and those
transitional objects are the first not
meet possessions that belong to the
child and beyond to the child only
insofar as everybody else in the family
says yes that's your teddy bear you can
go to bed with your teddy bear and so on
right so it requires the recognition of
everybody else and part of that social
phenomenon of everybody accepting that's
your teddy bear allows the child to make
that that transition helps make the
bridge and that's why it's this transit
moving from one place to another it's an
object that helps to bridge the
dissonance between the child psychic
trauma at this at this loss and the new
external reality that she begins to
discover so it is in this
additional social space that we find the
transitional object and in its in that
sense that I was very fascinated by your
sense of the music scene as a
transitional space as opposed to you
know a kind of CD but that you're really
beginning to unpack this notion of the
transitional space and so I think this
relation between the transitional space
in the transitional object is something
for us to think about in relationship to
urban neighborhoods also because we have
been talking in the early panel also
about the relationship between the
physical urban space and the social and
I don't agree that we have that we
neglect as architects to talk about
these two things I think what we are
trying to do is precisely to understand
the relationship and I thought maybe
these questions of the transitional are
a way to kind of unpack this this
relationship because for instance in
relatively recent scholarship like
Robert Young in the book mental space
has provided an exposition of the notion
of transitional object to concept more
generalized and more about the role of
psychic phenomena and adult life so that
you know has extended this notion to not
just to the child but also to the way
that we as adults also use transitional
objects so it seems to me that in the
experience of transnationalism music
text out weaving traditions and so on
might be ways in which people kind of
deal with this with the trauma the cost
of liberalisation and in ways in which
things like monuments that fail to do
that like these these monumental Latin
American monument to Latin America and
so on so that's that's as far as I want
to take it in terms of my opening in
response to your papers and maybe as a
way for us to have a conversation I
could maybe ask Erica to begin and
launch us off if you could really maybe
expand a little bit
on this question of the dissonance
between the Japanese music scene and the
Peruvian de kasagi music scene and the
way that which it seemed to me at least
there was an instrumental turning away
from each other and especially on the
side of the Japanese the they're
Japanese seen serves as a very kind of
violent cultural practice of not
recognizing other music scenes and in a
sense not saying that is your
transitional object somehow and saying
you know it does it does not exist we
don't recognize that is your you're
right so maybe you could you could
expand to us how these two things really
relate to one another is there really no
connection or there's an awareness that
it exists in a kind of attempt to really
make it disappear well one thing should
be said about the particular pattern of
migration taken America migration to
Japan so when you say the word my ones
like late in American migrants Amy you
say in Japanese the Japanese don't
usually think about peruvian brazilians
in japan to think about when their
ancestors went to late in america so
there is a very low level of knowledge
about the situation of latin america
in particular in in Japan so if the
normal Japanese especially those living
center of Tokyo don't usually know about
the existence of these communities or
made up of minus of course they see
Latino the instructors salsa dance
instructions are almost Cubans or like
some programs so they they know there
are some late in America model but they
don't know really the situation of the
market is not a knowledge in Japan
because there is simply no information
about this apart from this last year and
a half because of the of the recession
so there is a bit more of information so
i wouldn't say that it's the lady music
scene doesn't include the latino because
the it's not economically important so
wait even if you talk to producer user
distributors of late music they are not
interested in the in the market made up
of latino residents whether Peruvians or
argentineans because they are not they
don't spend money in that and they don't
participate aqui actively economically
speaking in the market so they apart
from the fact that most of them don't
know that there are like Layton American
violence in Japan they are not
interested in their participation
because the Japanese that true even that
that Japanese don't know that there are
Peruvians in their country I mean they
know of course now 20 years have passed
so people living in central and avoid
for example or people living in Yokohama
which is an area historical with weed
once a full of migrants but with many
foreigners so but they don't know the
situation they are just the kiseki they
are those working in the factories but
they they don't really have a concrete
image of what means like if you go to
Spain or here in the United States or in
my country Italy the magnetism
visible presence so you know and he used
it in the street and he business are
very very pleasant but for example like
there were areas like I would say some
part in Kanagawa Prefecture and someone
in Aichi efecto where you can see a kind
of integration because of closeness ok
maybe on this question of the of the
visibility you know there there's
something quite disturbing about the BIA
acceptance of the invisible and I wanted
to maybe turn to You Vladimir because I
had real trouble with your use of the
word pace out and you're assuming
acceptance of that as a way to describe
the Bolivian presence in in Brazil as a
kind of tranquil presence and it seemed
to me that some of the kind of
projection of a kind of veil over what's
actually want you on the one hand
revealed you know you open up these
interiors where there is a real
suffering going on and then on the other
hand you you give us this this term
basis as a way to describe it and it
seemed to me a real dissonance between
what we've showed in the pictures and
the fat in this notion of Pisa isn't
this space is really one that is forced
upon the Bolivians and not so much what
you know this in a sense it deprives
them of political agency the very fact
that they're denied housing you see my
mean yeah yes I think so and thank you
for a comments adoption we have some
problems in the use of the term passage
passaging in Portuguese or enlightened
idioms we use
different in different way to refer to
natural features and to urban scene
let's say in English is different i know
when i used the the tempest as passaging
as some feature that people can
recognize physiognomy in this this this
bit of the deceit in this part of the
city they they are familiar with this
district this part of the city this is
the meaning I want to use it's not let's
say a beautiful set setting or peaceful
but is something that's recognizable the
kick am taking find themselves in this
space of course it doesn't mean that the
troubles or the traumas are solvent but
and a massage not not means only a
tranquil or a serenity it means
something that you with with which you
have an effective relationship and and
they have this this effective and
effective is not always a very pleasant
thing but it affects you so it's in this
sense I
i tried to use the term massage I don't
know if I answer your question feel free
to jump in when you'd like to and if you
have a question just raise your hand and
and I'll alcohol upon you as as we can
so just I'll be looking out okay yeah I
would like to talk about invisibility I
think it's very important when anime
welcome at least in Spain but we are
living there is that they change
completely trying to rotate as a local
as a local resident for example
Bolivians are one of the largest
community in Spain or even though in
Madrid mainly know and they lose
immediately their clothes very specific
clothes they use daily in MO Libya and
they stopped speaking Aymara most of
dinner I'm others so they speak
sometimes have very poor Spanish but we
prefer even not to talk ever keep silent
so so this question of invisibility is
our protection for them on the other
side to find a home house is almost
impossible when they arrive for if they
don't down relation down getting in
touch with their own group because they
cannot get her house from the residence
because they have no guarantee they no
have no paper and have nothing enough
almost the same with the government on
the public public social house in a zone
they are not even exist the only option
is to live in their own community and
they here is another strange question is
not only to to improve something
emotional that it is of course but it is
a
city and these necessities is has become
something perverse that produce a lot of
abuses in housing precisely because all
this conflict know so in visibilities
are like on our shield to protect
themselves against t gustan system but
keep inside our abuses sir microphone
there was a question from the audience
do you want to respond to that air and
so your ear observation is absolutely
right because the there is something
about Cuba Oh first of all I should say
that Cuba music and very early in Japan
then there was like kind of period it
was not the board the recent revival is
different from the first Cuban music
that entered Japan but there is
something about Cuba specifically which
is a kind of nostalgia you were saying
something like it's kind of I would say
exoticism toward Cuba and and the lady
music escape which is a thing which is
very much like a Japanese peculiarity
that I mean Tokyo this is the
fascinating but about Tokyo you go to
some places and you see people dressed
according to the plat place even when
you take the train you can I mean I'm
really in Tokyo nine years so you get
the train and you can guess this person
is coming from that area so the lady
music scene implies the fact of being
wearing shoes for dancing style for the
kind of the style which is supposedly
more the Latin dance style according to
Japan so this is this is one at the same
time the music is a soothing for a
Peruvian with with the cumbia and of
course there is a lot of salsa Queen
conveyancing but also for japanese
because in such a stress life this
afterwards Sansa classes I know people
that they go to work with the salsa
closing into the bag and then they go to
the sunset club and they changing in the
toilet and then they change they need
two months I think this is also a way
really like when they say they use it
like to to get rid of stress this is
also true and this this this fact of of
fashion dressing up of slowing down the
tempo is definitely related to the late
music scene because you don't you join
you don't go there just to be in a lady
in places but you go there in order to
perform like let's say and a different
identity in a sense their other
questions was in a user one okay
how oh thank you how you and your
students have thought about the issue
I've sort of given the reality of real
estate markets I don't know specifically
how they work in Madrid but I sort of
can imagine some basic things it seems
like some of those that design plans
that your students were coming up with
involved eliminating some of the kind of
geographical and and layout kind of
defects of the neighborhood that had
made it a low-rent area which had
enabled these sort of marginal groups to
live there and how have you thought
about the issue that if some of those
defects are eliminated it might cease to
be alone red neighborhood and that might
initiate a process of displacement is
that me is that a factor yes I
understand because this is what this was
the first question the students the
students did at the beginning we cannot
displace people this is not the solution
no of course perhaps in this very short
explanation is impossible to achieve or
to explain that but I can clarify now
the this neighborhood is really very bad
used I mean with this is a very the
compactness the density the feeling of
density is very high because it's very
dark it's very narrow uncomfortable but
in fact the density is very low because
all these small houses where
self-construction houses very all very
but quality so it's very easy to
compensate the intensity if you remove a
part of the area then area you can
increase in another part so that was a
departure point for all people working
there you cannot displace people living
here so the proposals are proposals done
by today
architects all of them master degree but
anyway our broom academic proposals you
see but all of them were aware about
these things and they have to give a
solution to this if they remove
something or people remove should be
replaced in some weight there may be in
the back and then we could we'll take
both questions hi um I wonder if there's
any like urban policy or municipal
policies that are directed specifically
at the immigrant communities like
exclusion exclusionary because I
understand that people are sort of
marginalized by the economic conditions
but I wonder if there's any specific
urban policy that's been created to kind
of further you know further marginalized
the peruvians Bolivians Colombians
Ecuadorians etc let's take them so first
for Erica you mentioned Japanese I'm
sorry Brazilian immigrants I'm wondering
if you could elaborate a little bit
about maybe if there's a musical a
comparative musical store you could tell
about Japanese I'm sorry Brazilian
immigrants to Japan and then for
Vladimir you mentioned this monument to
Latin America designed by oscar niemeyer
and it's interesting to me because it's
meant to be sort of an inclusive thing
to sort of talk about Latin American
unity and yet it's being used as sort of
a ghettoized space for performing
Bolivian culture and I wonder if this is
maybe analogous to one thing that
surprises me in Brazil is Latin America
seems to be somewhere else and these
immigrants are called Latinos and so I
wonder if it's maybe there's kind of an
analogy there
maybe we can whoever wants to take a mic
please please do well about policies
this is a for example in the case of
Spain and in the case of Madrid
regarding public governmental or local
arena there are not urban policies
regarding immigrants and it's a question
I did yes one week before i come here in
a forum i had the chance to us directly
to hide responsive responsables of the
city hall for example there are in spain
a lot of laws in this period trying to
get better the best condition the best
social and right human rights and so on
conditions and sometimes there are
processed in order to legalize all the
illegal immigrants and many many rights
they have a lot of social rights I
consider really of course as a residence
as National Citizen of colorful for the
health care for schools they have all
rights legal and illegal everyone but I
think the process is going so fast that
is not nothing is nothing done in in the
spatial and urban and housing aspects
it's a lock complete luck and i think is
tied to it probably if you analyze her
neighbor who like this with this whole
holistic view it is very easy to find
solutions but probably it is not done by
the city hall or regional or national
governments I think these are lock will
be very important to improve
and about the urban policies in the case
of Bolivar immigrants in physical terms
we had not because the we believe in
concentrate in Sao Paulo is different
from the normal way immigrants used to
to to stay there we can not consider as
a ghetto not a ethnic session not as a
perfect or suburban agglomeration nor as
a camp offer refugees let's say although
they concentrating in certain districts
they don't characterize this district as
in less so in a such strong way like
Italian or Japanese did so i think it's
not it's not possible to do to have our
special special n-space polish but on
the other hand if we consider the legal
condition there are some initiative some
things that believe in government
providing block mates for them and this
like an agreement between bodies and
consulate and president entities to
facilitate the documentation of the
illegal ones even in the half sorry the
health policies something's something r
is going on in hospitals that are like
let's say the spc specialized in
affordable even some help in the health
in their half another point you comment
it's about the way brazilian see lake in
America it's the first time that we
receive an alkene American immigration
is about we never had did this
immigration that this kind of
immigration before so it's a novelty for
us and of course there are many problems
to assimilate them because i think they
are poor they are Lego men men things
that I i said but one thing that we can
recognize now is the is like a
consumption of culture the street market
can put ice it mark although being
segregated now is announced in the
newspaper people
it starts being fashionable to be there
you know some something is happening
about this but they just beginning that
the cemetery searcher I don't have more
more strong than servitude to give you
we've come so they thanked end of our
time here for this panel but I would
like since there's so many questions in
the earth and and you had one pending I
would like to suggest that we maybe have
the conversation over lunch since we
have some time for that and we reconvene
at 240 is that correct so please join me
in thanking our panelists for their
presentation